Context-free grammars always produce a finite number of utterances.
No. This one produces an infinite number of utterances.
I can keep looping around rule one as many times as I want.
And in fact, this is one of the glories of context-free grammars--
that they can often accept an infinite number strings,
thus, giving you room for creativity based on just a finite grammar.
Context-free grammars can capture a^N b^N.
Yes. It looks like this. Just like the balanced parentheses one but with "ab" instead.
So by "yes" I of course meant "Yes."
Context-free grammars are more powerful than regular expressions. Yes.
Here, more powerful or more expressive means that there are some languages--
remember, a language is set of string--that context-free grammars
can recognize that regular expressions cannot.
This is one of them, a^N b^N can't be captured by regular expressions,
but it can be done by context-free grammars. Therefore, they are more powerful.
Context-free grammars can tell if a program declares a variable before using it.
No. If you think back to our grammars for JavaScript, we couldn't tell the difference
between a variable that had been declared than one that had not been yet.
That's a context-sensitive property. We won't be able to check it with context-free grammars.
We could only notice that later when we are doing interpreting or in a statically typed language
if we were type-checking things to make sure we are using integers and strings correctly.
We might also check to see which variables were in scope.
But in general, it's very hard to tell if a variable has already been used.
That depends on the previous program. That previous program is the context.
Context-free grammars don't get any context.